exactly platinum and he had nas and
jay-z on a song together
shaq was playing what's the song i don't
know but you see what i'm saying the
name of it but this is what i mean by
about the rapping [ __ ] like i feel like
we all took a l until somebody's singing
our lyrics
that's real like music is about breaking
stop the rain by shaq man you still
don't know it you can't stop the rain
come on that [ __ ] was i mean that wasn't
his part it was a great hook though
no that's fair i think damien has i
think
tell me about a sampled hook do you
think he starts singing himself do you
think big his part
do you think damon's at least done the
best job of like
juggling both no i think dame is a
superstar athlete with
the money to put behind it i don't think
that i think the nba is way more lenient
with dame doing stuff like letting him
perform for all-star doing all this
which i'm happy for him i'm not hating
i'm just saying
if i was a rock star like if i if i
never played under mello and stat and
when i went to new york it was just my
[ __ ] and we just was i was the rookie
that get to shoot it 30 times and do
whatever the [ __ ] i want right my music
would it it went different because it
was like nba can't say nothing
let him shoot 30 shots a game to where
it's like
pressure or not yeah i'm shooting until
i get in the mix like right like in high
school it's like bro whether i'm having
a good stint a bad stint i'm i got the
ball so much i could sort of get in
rhythm you get in a groove you know what
i mean like it was like if i if i had
that
then it's like they would have never hit
me with the oh he's not focused then
it's like if i say a curse word or two
who cares my [ __ ] i'm signing for 100
million like yeah also if you're a human
being people cuss that's what i'm
[ __ ] growing up in which i started to
realize once i'm like 27 i'm like bro
[ __ ] y'all i got a daughter like